les maisons de disques françaises ne
sont pas très nombreuses et certaines
connaissent des difficultés quand il
s'agit de la vente de disques classiques
ces difficultés sont quelque peu
sérieuse sans vouloir faire de publicité
pour quiconque on peut dire que des
firmes comme hadès à riom où arménien
hommes m'ont dit font un travail
courageux un travail de qualité mais
qu'elles sont souvent plus riche
d'espoirs que de moyens aussi l'on peut
peut-être marquer de la satisfaction en
assistante au mariage de l'une de ces
maisons et râteau avec gaumont la grande
société de production cinématographique
qui entre ainsi dans le monde du disque
je vous invite est libre maintenant une
enquête sur ce mariage mené par yoba
grégoire
a marché a beaucoup marché
pierre boulez dirige d'histoire du
soldat de stravinsky avec l'ensemble
intercontemporain et les comédiens
patrice chéreau antoine vitez et roger
planchon
beaucoup parfaire est événement musical
sans registre en ce moment pour erato
firme française que dirige avec une
minutie d'arbres jean michel garcin
alors monsieur planchon vous êtes en
forme ça a l'air d'aller fabien bon ben
on peut recommencer peut-être
le temps que j'ai fait par exemple en
angleterre et aux états unis de
travailler naturellement pour
des films pour une firme qui était
nettement anglo saxon des années
américaine est là avec un râteau
naturellement c'est un domaine qui est
plus spécifiquement dix ans au départ
nationale mais ce qui n'empêche pas
étant donné la structure de retournement
d'avoir une division mondiale qui est
intéressant tout de même on ne peut pas
se cantonner seulement faire des
discours un seul pays et il faut être
assuré de la diffusion en général et je
crois que dans ce cas là on a réuni si
vous voulez le surplace et la diffusion
aujourd'hui pierre boulez mais ira tôt
c'était déjà le trompettiste maurice
andré le flûtiste jean pierre rampal
c'était aussi le te deum de charpentier
devenu l'indicatif de leur vision
actuellement erato vend chaque année
deux millions cinq cent mille disques
près des deux tiers à l'étranger si pour
la france la troisième film de musique
classique malgré cela et malgré 25 % des
actions vendues aux amériques à la
maison manqué de disponibilité pour se
maintenir et se développer la société
gaumont en rachetant erato veut en faire
la rivale les plus grandes élargir le
catalogue et exporter davantage il est
évident que l'or comme disait malraux
est aussi une industrie
je trouve qu'à verts en france une
carence au niveau industriel et que
quand j'ai su qu'une maison comme erato
aussi importante dans son histoire par
son poids se trouvait à prendre j'ai
pensé que l'occasion était là vous savez
on fait des discours a posteriori mais
tout se passait comme herman d'amour les
avec la vie des affaires mais ils ont
dit que vous allez revendre une certaine
partie de vos actions à une firme
américaine
oui le problème est à l'envers à savoir
que cette grande maison américaine avait
depuis déjà quelques années une présence
dans le capital de la société avait
surtout une option sur la société et
qu'il a fallu toute notre énergie et la
compréhension des liens dans ces
sociétés pour accepter de ne pas
racheter et râteaux donc c'est au
contraire nous qui avons pu limiter leur
présence qui sera de toute façon tout à
fait minoritaire donc et avec un
avantage
que nous est très positif pour nous à
savoir que leur présence de la société
va nous l'espérons nous donner des
possibles des distributions dans le
monde entier qui sont supérieures à
celles d'une société française qui reste
petit
pour le moment mais le
deal est
un bon mariage pourrait râteau mais
d'autres maisons français cherchent des
prétendants ou en tout cas l'aide que
mary kelly fort qu'elles font pour le
développement de la culture et danses au
son nez vous qu'ils sachent qu'à présent
ma patience est